- Good morning believe nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe and
I believe that you have
something special that
when you unleash it,
it will be able to change the world.
And so to help you on your journey,
today's message is be confident.
Over to you, A$AP Rocky.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every mornin
♫ Entspresso keep me goin
- When you sort of first
knew that you had that moment
that confidence, when you felt it.
- When I was poor, man.
It's just like, I don't
think confidence is something
that you could buy, it's
something that's embedded in you
and some people gain it with success,
that's just like the icing on the cake,
but a poor man with
confidence is unstoppable,
almost invincible.
(crowd cheering)
- A poor man with
confidence is unstoppable.
I love that quote, I love
the message and I agree.
The next question then becomes,
well how to you get that confidence.
If you're in a bad
environment, if you're poor,
if you don't have great people around you,
how do you get that confidence.
And some people may be
born with it, I don't know.
For me, it was much more
about changing my environment.
And so I got confidence,
some of it from my parents,
Belief came from them.
They always told me I was
Evan Castrilli Carmichael,
I could do whatever I wanted
and that gave me a sense of confidence.
But if I look then into
my entrepreneurial career,
a lot of it came from my
habits and what I was reading
and now later into the videos.
By surrounding myself with
people that are confident,
that are doing big things.
Not necessarily in my actual life,
you know I don't have a
ton of super successful
super confident friends
that I hang around with.
It's much more from aspirational mentors
and I created the YouTube channel in part
selfishly for myself.
The top 10 rules selfishly for myself.
To be around greatness,
to be around success
on a regular basis.
And you could do that
for yourself as well.
If you want to develop
confidence, it may come by
watching videos on seven
ways to get more confident,
or reading books on how
to be more confident.
Kind of those tactical how to's,
but I think a lot of it also comes from
just the environment, just from osmosis.
Just by being around confident people.
And some of that wears off on you, right?
It's why I started the Mentor Me series.
Let's hang around people that
have done a lot more than us,
and some of their
mindsets and their beliefs
and the way that they think about things
seeps into us to help us
become the best version
of ourselves, not to be the
next Elon Musk or Steve Jobs
or whoever, but a more confident,
better version of ourselves.
And there was a point
where it really struck me,
where I was driving with
my father in the car
and I just signed a
deal with Stephen Kelly,
who's the CEO of Sage, and he
runs a multi-billion dollar
company with 10,000 to 15,000 employees,
and we're both doing this Q&A,
we're answering questions,
I'm hosting the show,
we get a question from
an entrepreneur, he
answers it, I answer it,
and my dad asks me, how do
you get the confidence to
be on par with Stephen
Kelly, that you're his equal,
that you're answering
questions alongside him.
It wasn't in a you suck kind of tone,
it was a general admiration,
like where did that come from?
Like that's amazing, in a supportive way.
And I thought about it, and
it's really from the videos.
You know it's really from all this work,
because I'm hanging around
Elon Musk and Kanye West
and Snoop Dogg and Martha
Stewart and all of these
successful people, whether
they're athletes or musicians
or entrepreneurs, I'm
around that constantly.
And so, seeing people being
confident and going off
and doing great things
makes me be more confident.
And so, by hanging around greatness more,
you unleash a little bit
more greatness inside
of yourself as well.
And the more you do that and
the more consistent you are
with that, then the more
it's going to come out.
So I agree that a poor man with confidence
will be unstoppable, the
question then becomes
how to you get that confidence.
And if you weren't born with
it, I think that's okay.
I think there's so much that you can do
by changing your habits, by
changing your environment,
by surrounding yourself
with maybe not people,
like you may not have people around you,
but by resources,
information, videos, guides
of confident, successful
people that will unleash
that inner boldness in you to
go off and do amazing things.
So the question of the
day today is, I'm curious,
how do you get more
confidence for the big things
that you're doing in your life.
Leave it down in the comments below,
super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Kiley Brown aka AnalogSoul.
Kiley, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, I really
hope you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you.
I hope that you continue
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see you
guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
(typing noise)
- [Mike Tyson] While I'm
in the dressing room,
five minutes before I come
out, my gloves are laced up,
I'm breaking my gloves down,
I'm pushing the leather
in the back of my gloves.
I'm breaking the middle of
the glove for my knuckle.
Could pierce though the
leather, I could feel my knuckle
piercing against it, tight leather gloves
on that Everlast boxing gloves.
When I come out I have supreme confidence,
but I'm scared to death.
I'm totally afraid, I'm
afraid of everything.
I'm afraid of losing, I'm
afraid of being humiliated,
but I was totally confident.
The closer I get to the ring,
the more confident I get.
The closer, more confidence I get.
All during my training I've
been afraid of this man.
I thought this man might
be capable of beating me.
I've dreamed of him beating me.
But that went by.
Always stayed afraid of him.
But as closer I get to the
ring, I'm more confident.
Once I'm in the ring, I'm a god.
No one could beat me.
(crowd cheering)
I walk around the ring
but I never take my eyes
off my opponent.
I keep my eyes on, even
if he's ready and pumped
and he can't wait to get
his hands on me as well.
I keep my eyes on him,
I keep my eyes on him.
Then once I see a chink
in his armor, boom,
and one of his eyes may move,
and then I know I have him.
Then when he comes to
the center of the ring,
he still looks at me
with his piercing look
and as if he's not afraid,
but he already made that
mistake when he looked down
for that 1/10 of a
second, I know I had him.
He'll fight hard for the
first two or three rounds,
but I know I already broke his spirit.
During the fight, I'm supremely confident.
I'm moving my head, he's throwing punches.
I'm making and missing
them, and I'm countering.
I'm hitting to the body,
I'm punching real hard.
And I'm punching, and
when I'm punching him,
I know he's not able to take my punches.
One, two, three punches,
I'm throwing them punches
in bunches.
He goes down, he's out.
I'm victorious.
Mike Tyson, greatest
fighter who ever lived.
- When you go into a
race, you have to go there
always confident.
You can't go in there thinking
that the guy next to me
is going to beat me today.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- No you have to, even if you
know he's going to beat you,
you got to be confident
that I'm going to give him
a run for his money today.
I'm going to give my best.
You can't worry about anybody else .
Because he may come out
and have a really bad day.
Then what?
So you got to be ready, just
in case he has a bad day.
- Yeah.
- So you got to be on
your game at all times.
- Feel confident.
Dress to impress yourself.
When you leave the house
look in the mirror.
Look at yourself, and
if you don't go damn,
then you need to change.
Feel like a million bucks.
And that doesn't mean you
have to spend a million bucks.
You don't need that Gucci
Gucci, Fendi Fendi, Prada Prada,
you can be rockin that
straight 725 from Wal-Mart
and still be hella hot.
I'm saying, make sure
when you leave the house
you're dressed in an outfit
that you feel confident in.
If you're worrying
about your crack showing
and you know, your booby
popping out, and you know
your pants being too tight
or too loose or something,
you're not going to feel confident.
You need to feel sexy,
you need to feel hot,
you need to feel smokin'.
And everyone is beautiful
in their own way,
so don't give me no B.S. about I'm ugly
and my hair's ugly and skin is ugly.
What the hell was that?
And my skin is ugly,
and just everything. No.
Everyone is beautiful in their own way,
so don't give me that crap, okay.
That means you just need to
connect with your inner swag,
and get it poppin.